we will bring you the police news
conference from Tennessee once it starts
in the meantime our patriotism and hard
work a thing of the past in Joe Biden's
America the left's endless bashing of
the United States showcased in a
stunning new poll just 38 percent of
Americans say patriotism is very
important to them a severe drop from 70
percent in 1998 and worse there are now
less Americans who respect and
appreciate hard work it's no wonder when
the White House is focused on equity and
handouts
this is about equity
and whether or not we are truly
committed to the principles of equity in
every way that we as government and as a
society can enforce those important
principles one of the reasons I'm so
optimistic about this nation is that
today's generation of Young Americans is
the most Progressive thoughtful
inclusive generation that America has
ever seen forcing us to confront the
huge gap in economy and excuse me
economic inequity yes Force us to
confront systemic racism and white
supremacy the obsession with woke is
being driven by liberals 56 percent of
Democrats want companies taking a public
stance on social and political issues
while 80 percent of Republicans oppose
it and if you criticize the left's hyper
focus on being woke then they will call
you a racist
the whole discussion about woke is
really a dog whistle against
African-American against black people
against people of color the things that
they are deeming as woke are the things
that are trying to make us a more
inclusive country by having books by
letting our children learn about others
other than themselves
all right Jeff see I'll start with you
it appears that you know the left is
pushing Equity uh which considers the
outcome uh as opposed to uh equality of
opportunity uh and now we've got these
numbers that are indicating that fewer
and fewer people are even interested in
working hard
well hard work's been replaced by quotas
everybody wants to be rewarded for
something they didn't really deserve
just because you look a certain way or
you identify a certain way doesn't mean
you deserve a job or a promotion it used
to be you worked hard you get ahead and
now people want to get ahead just by the
color of their skin or just because they
wanted to sleep with some certain person
that doesn't matter also they're against
hard work because life's too easy now
you have an app for that you can have
someone come over and be your handyman
make your bed do your dishes deliver
your food everyone has a butler in their
phone so that's also a part of it the
patriotism thing I understand because
the farther away you get from World War
II the farther away you get from the
Cold War the less competitive you feel
as a country it used to be communism
versus capitalism and now it's globalism
now it's just about open markets free
trade and you know America is the top
guy but you know what we don't not
really deserve it and we feel bad about
our position if you get to the war on
terror situation remember that was more
of a nuisance that way they called it a
global war but that was like a little a
pesky nuisance that you could mop up
with surgical strikes and then remember
they were mad at us because it was our
fault and we can't fight back because we
don't want to spark more islamophobia
the Iraq War was a mistake Afghanistan
went on and on so you don't really get
that patriotism that we used to really
feel what made us Americans
okay so Jessica I mean this poll shows a
22 percent drop in young adults ages 25
and Below saying that they're extremely
proud to be American what is that about
I think so across the board with the
poll all of the categories were split on
age lines so if you talk to senior
citizens they still feel good amounts of
patriotism they're still relatively
religious Etc so it's obviously a
generational thing that's happening here
I think Jessie's right that there's so
much distance now from what people
generally consider to be a just War
right something that you want to support
maybe get involved with
um on obviously post 911 the 911 moment
itself was a great moment for American
patriotism we were all completely
unified and we really haven't had that
since then
um so I think it's about younger
Generations just generally feeling
differently I thought the money question
was really interesting too about how
that's the only thing Democrats and
Republicans are the value that's gone up
that everyone wants more money but young
people just see the world differently
and I think part of that is on us to do
a better job articulating what makes our
country special why even if there are
things that you don't like about the way
the country works that is still better
than a lot of other options
it does frustrate me though on the
religion question they never talk about
spirituality which has replaced religion
for a lot of people and I'm not saying
that for those who are religious that
it's an equal thing it's not just
meditating Jesse religion is very much
and I'm not uh
I don't go to synagogue regularly I
certainly identify I'm proud to be
Jewish but I understand religion more as
being part of a community and having a
support system and you can get that very
much through being a spiritual person so
I think that should be one of the
questions you know the the truth is that
it is as Jessica says you know or Jesse
said the only priority that grew in
importance was money and that's amazing
because covet created a generation where
everyone became accustomed to you know
receiving money they don't want to work
and in bidens America they just don't
want to work I don't how do you how do
you rationalize those two the government
destroy young people's future by the
decisions that they made whether it was
an education or just taking away big
life events like college graduation high
school state championships things that
shape you as a person for your future
that was taken away through years of
overbearing coveted policy whether it
was on the federal level or on the state
level but when it comes to the question
you had about being proud to be in
America American when all of the
institutions government institutions
colleges even Elementary K-12 education
teaches young people that America is a
Bad Country we shouldn't be surprised
that they don't have any feelings about
patriotism especially since they're
young and they haven't traveled to the
rest of the world to see how the rest of
the world operates I'm not talking about
going into even to Europe although
Europe will make you appreciate America
but going to third world countries or
seeing the despair that the rest of the
world is in or just to see the good
things that America is doing around the
world the other thing I would say is
that
we've focused so much on equity and four
years ago people said that tolerance was
80 80 of people said it was very
important to them now it's down to 58
they've been pushing Equity as if that's
going to make everybody more tolerant it
actually requires everybody to
discriminate against one another and to
see each other as their differences not
as the same
um because you're looking for certain
characteristics rather than judging
Everybody by the same standard and
people who work the hardest get to the
top and instead we're all judging each
other by what makes this very different
instead of the same all right Greg just
one in seven Americans think that the
country is headed in the right direction
how do we change that around when every
time Biden talks he's blaming the
Republicans well I think a lot of this
was intentional over the last 20 or 30
years what we've what it what have we
replaced patriotism with We have
replaced it with a different kind of
Pride it's identity politics we've gone
from pride in our country to Pride in
our identity so which one is better you
know well the media picked its horse
it's identity but pride in your country
is isn't necessarily uh it's an idea
it's not like I'm proud to be an
American it's that I'm proud to be part
of an idea that makes this country
different that is why anybody can be an
American right they can come from
anywhere and as long and that's why
we're known as The Melting Pot we
weren't supposed to notice parts of the
Melting Pot right so you know the
country as an idea was supposed to bring
people together but what we've done is
we've replaced that Unity with something
completely that we were so it's
something that we weren't supposed to do
tribalism right now it's it's it's
everybody is their own sports team and
what happens is
now you've got a new kind of Pride which
one's better well identity politics is
the worst kind of Pride because I mean
it's actually pathetic if you are proud
of your identity in my I mean you had no
hand in your identity right uh am I
should I be proud of being white because
a white person invented the light bulb
a white person invented Penicillin I
didn't have anything to do with that I'm
proud of the things that I do that is
why America that's why Americans tend to
be proud is because we do things and and
being part of an American is to be to be
doing something as an American identity
politics uh completely deflates that
whether you're proud of your race or
your sexuality uh that's that you have
nothing to say for yourself it's
actually kind of sad I am very proud of
my sexuality
you know what you're the only one
everybody else is disgusted by yours
Jesse you want to expound on that for us
I wanna know all right I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now